in the event it hasn't taken them uh
that long to pay this back
no so every year when we uh try and
unpick
uh the royal finances there's often a
few things that raise eyebrows
and last year the big thing that stood
out was that 2.4
million pound bill to refurbish frogmore
cottage now
the reason that people again started
talking about just how much money it
cost to refurbish that cottage
was at the start of the year of course
harry and megan announced they wanted to
step away from royal duties
but also said that while they were
splitting their life between america
and the uk they still wanted to keep
frogmore cottage as
their main uk residence course people
then said well hang on a minute
taxpayers money was used to fund that
and if you're no longer going to be
working royals
uh how exactly is that fair now this
afternoon we've had this statement
which has come from a spokesperson for
the duke and duchess of sussex
which has now said that a contribution
has been made
to the sovereign grant by the duke of
sussex it goes on to say that this
contribution as originally offered by
prince harry
has fully covered the necessary
renovation costs of frogmore cottage
a property of her majesty the queen and
will remain
the uk residence of the duke and his
family now if you're not really sure
what the sovereign grant is all about
well in essence it's the package of
money that is used to pay for the
official work of the monarchy and her
family
and also the upkeep of their properties
and that sovereign grant money
comes from some of the profits that are
made by the crown estate which is a huge
portfolio of land
and properties which are in the gift of
the monarch most the profits go to the
treasury but a percentage goes to
funding their official work so that's
why it's often referred to
as taxpayers money i also think that in
a way
the due conduction of sussex their hand
has been forced in a way this week after
it was announced they'd signed that
enormous deal
with netflix neither netflix or the
sussexes have said exactly how much
money they're making from that deal
but it's estimated it could be around
100 million
pounds so if they're bringing in that
money it sort of makes sense that
they're now going to pay this money back
to the taxpayer of this home
that they still want to keep here in the
uk